jean marc sylvestre bonjour alors joe
biden est une chose des occidentaux ont
fait le pari que les talibans
respecteront leurs engagements ce qui
concerne une transition pacifique et
sans effusion de sang vite tout le monde
en doute est-ce qu'ils en ont les moyens
financiers
mais à écouter
vous avez raison la question de l'argent
nécessaire au fonctionnement de la
société afghane va se poser très vite
dès hier d'ailleurs on a vu les marchés
financiers et monétaires s'effondrer
dans la région la valeur de la monnaie
s'effondre et l'accès aux liquidités est
devenu très difficile dans les banques
qui sont quasiment fermé l'afghanistan
est un pays puissant avec près de 40
millions d'habitants il est très
modifiée ce traître il a très évolué par
rapport à aux années 2000 lorsque les
américains sont arrivés mais c'est un
pays fragile parce qu'il ne produit pas
de richesse très peu d'énergie très peu
de matière première du textile un peu de
l'agriculture wii qui permet aux
habitants de se nourrir à peu près à
leur fin mais pour le reste ils doivent
tout acheté à l'extérieur donc il faut
de l'argent il faut de l'argent et
l'argent de la guerre en afghanistan eh
bien ils provenaient jusqu'à maintenant
de trois sur vous voyez la première la
plus importante ce sont les aides
internationales le fmi les ong et
surtout l'état américain les aides
américaines qui était lié à la présence
des militaires américains s'est ému que
les américains ont évalué le total de
leurs contributions à 1000 milliards de
dollars en 20 ans 50 milliards par an
jusqu'à cette année c'est l'argent
qu'ils déversaient sur le terrain pour
l'entretien de leurs troupes mais aussi
qu'ils déversaient sur l'économie
afghane la deuxième source de revenus et
bien sûr les taxer les produits qui
entrent dans le pays et qui sont
lourdement taxés pas seulement par
l'état afghan 1 mais aussi par certaines
autorités locales des féodaux ça
représentait en gros 2 milliards voilà
bien ces revenus là par exemple on
disparaît avec le départ des étrangers
la fermeture des frontières alors reste
comme ressource celle de la drogue
personne n'en parle mais l'afghanistan
est devenu le premier producteur d'opium
et l'opium c'est évidemment l'héroïne et
c'est le premier producteur du monde
puisque les cultures occupent les
cultures de pavot 1 occupe 25 % des
terres agricoles elle couvre 90% des
besoins mondiaux de la consommation
mondiale c'est considérable est revenu
alors bien sûr on les connaît pas entre
trois et six milliards de dollars par an
et ses revenus font vivre les
agriculteurs font vivre des
transformateurs du commerce et tout ça
est sous le contrôle des jeux tout ça et
sur le contrôle des talibans et ça va
quand même être très très difficile de
savoir la vérité de ce point de vue là
parce que cet argent-là servait
notamment à acheter des armes et à faire
vivre ce pays alors en dehors de ses
activités il ya des entreprises normales
une vie économique normale bah écoutez
si vous posez la question c'est qu'on
doute un peu de de la normalité tout ça
la grosse erreur des américains est sans
doute de ne pas avoir su favoriser des
investissements générateurs
d'équipements et de richesses ce
chercheur afghans que vous avez
interrogé il ya un instant le le disait
il n'ya pas eu d'investissements en
équipements collectifs en équipement
industriel une grande partie de l'argent
déversé dans le pays a quand même été
capté par la corruption au profit de
chefs talibans alors en 20 ans
l'afghanistan a réussi à créer une
petite classe moyenne notamment dans les
grandes villes à kaboul par exemple six
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui il ya
des gens qui travaillent normalement il
ya des femmes qui sont allées à l'école
qui se sont affranchis de la charia qui
ont des travaux dans la santé dans
l'éducation mais ils sont minoritaires
et ils ont très peur ce sont ces femmes
là maintenant qu'ils ont peur maintenant
pour essayer de vous de continuer
justement cette normalité alors les
autorités américaines ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient bloquer les avoirs de l'état
afghan en dépôt à la banque centrale
américaine quelles vont être les effets
jean-marc oui alors là on éteint ses
lumières de la guerre ça doit
représenter 2 à 3 milliards qui
appartiennent à l'état afghan et qui
sont en dépôt à washington mais ça c'est
super c'est classique je veux dire que
tous les états ont des dépôts dans la
plupart des autres banques banques
centrales pour pour effectuer les
transferts ça appartient à l'état a
voulu en mai où elle est a avoué
aujourd'hui alors cessé c'est assez
classique je vous disais de la part des
états qui décident de bloquer les dépôts
les avoirs en attendant que la situation
se stabilise et que les structures
étatiques s'organise depuis hier la
ville de kaboul est en rupture de
liquidité avec une valeur de la monnaie
je vous disais qu'il s'est effondré avec
une banque centrale de kaboul qui est
quasiment fermé avec un gouverneur de la
banque centrale qui est parti se
réfugier à l'étranger cela dit c'est une
arme à double tranchant pour propos pour
les occidentaux c'est un moyen de faire
pression bien sûr sur les talibans qui
vont avoir des problèmes de trésorerie
pour payer les soldes de leurs
combattants surtout pour payer les
fonctionnaires qui l'ont rassuré en leur
garantissant une immunité mais ne rompt
pas garanti de le traitement il va
falloir à la fin du mois les payer avec
quel argent on ne sait pas cela dit les
occidentaux ne peuvent pas asphyxier
complètement l'afghanistan pourquoi
parce que à ce moment là l'afghanistan
risque une radicalisation extrême des
talibans avec toutes les menaces de
terrorisme international dont ils
peuvent laisser planer la possibilité je
pense que tout le monde a intérêt à ce
que les accords de transition qui
avaient été signés soit respectée à
commencer par les talibans m jean marc
sylvestre journaliste et éditorialiste
économique merci pour ces précisions